we've thrown
a lot of disasters at earth over the
years
from asteroids and aliens to the sun's
death but hey the universe is a
dangerous place
and we're not done yet
[Music]
now we're going to throw a black hole
into the mix and
not just any black hole but a blazar
how old is the oldest blazar
why can we see some blazars but not
others and what is the doppler effect
and
how would it let us know that a blazar
is on its way
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if a blazar entered our solar system
black holes are found at the center of
most galaxies
the milky way has a black hole that is
four million times the mass of the sun
but that's small compared to other black
holes out there
for instance there's pso j0309 plus
27 this galaxy is the oldest ever
discovered
at around 13 billion years old and
since the universe is only 13.8 billion
years old
pso j0309 plus 27 has basically
been around almost since the beginning
at the center of this galaxy
is a super massive black hole that
could fit 250 black holes from the milky
way
because of this crazy big black hole
pso j0309 plus two seven is
considered to be a blazar and blazars
are the most
extreme type of active galactic nuclei
or agn for short but
what are active galactic nuclei
well there are different types a blazar
being just one of them
but basically they're galaxies with
supermassive black holes that spew
tons of energy which could range from
radio waves
to gamma rays because they give off so
much energy
they are the brightest objects in the
universe
so what makes a blazar special
we'll get back to these galactic events
soon but first i wanted to talk to you
about
morning brew and no i'm not talking
about a cup of coffee
it's a free newsletter that i get daily
every morning you know i used to spend
my mornings going down a rabbit hole on
reddit now i spend just five minutes
reading up on all things business
finance tech morning brew isn't dry and
boring like
traditional news it's witty relevant and
informative
it keeps me up to date on everything
from the us and china making a joint
statement about climate change to
the roller coaster that is
cryptocurrency
morningbrew is also the sponsor of
today's video
if you're interested in business finance
or tech there's
really no reason not to subscribe to
morning brew it's completely free
and it takes less than 15 seconds to
subscribe
just click in the link in the
description and subscribe today
blazars are extremely rare there are
anywhere from
200 billion to 2 trillion
galaxies in the universe and only one
out of every 10 000 galaxies are blazars
but what makes them really spectacular
are the jets of
material shooting out from the top and
bottom of their rotating discs
these jets are supercharged with
magnetic fields and radiation
the material inside them can travel just
under the speed of light
and their lethal radiation beams are
pointed straight
at earth let me be clear
it's not just some blazars that are
pointed toward us
but all of them any blazars
that aren't pointing their deadly jets
in our direction
are invisible to us so
what blazar would be the most likely to
enter our solar system
let's go with the closest one to earth
markarian 421
at 400 million light years away
how would we know it's coming and when
would it start
affecting earth well scientists
would know that mercarian 421 is getting
closer to earth
almost right away the light from the
blazar
would change from red to blue changes to
the light's
wavelength would cause this and it has
to do with the doppler effect
this is a hard one to explain so i'm
going to use a metaphor
you've just pulled over to clear a path
for an ambulance and as the ambulance
approaches you
its siren has a higher frequency but
once it passes and
speeds away from you its siren has a
lower frequency
both sound and light behave like waves
so you can use the same idea for the
doppler effect
when a galaxy moves away from you the
frequency of its wavelengths
become lower and shift toward red when a
galaxy moves toward you
its wavelengths have a higher frequency
and shift toward blue
most galaxies in the universe are
red-shifted because
the universe is expanding so if
mercarian 4-2-1 suddenly changed to blue
astronomers would know right away that
it was heading toward us
how long would we have well even at the
speed of light
it would take marcarian 421 400 million
years to reach earth
but it doesn't have to reach earth to
cause damage
its jet could be hundreds of thousands
of light years long
our galaxy is only 100 light years
across
so markarian 421 would begin blasting
our solar system
with radiation before it even entered
the milky way
blazars are also known to blast off
from time to time this giant flare
can last from minutes to months if
marcarion 421 blasted off within a range
of our galaxy
its jet would punch a hole straight
through our solar system
it would be a doomsday scenario and
there wouldn't be anything we could do
to save ourselves but luckily
this solar system ending event is low on
our list of things to freak out about
there are lots of other things that have
a higher chance of happening like
an asteroid colliding with earth
but that's a story for another
what if
you